Vini, what’s wrong?
Look at me,
doing menial household labor day
in day out for my mother,
but what I dream of is to do
menial household labor day in
day out for my gorgeous emotionally unavailable husband.
♪♪
You’ll be making my wedding
dress, Betty, for sure.
Are you getting married?
Someday.
Oh my God, Joseph, you came.
How are you?
Um, I made a pillow for my cat.
Lavinia, every time we throw a
party, I find you with your hair
tied around some boys neck.
It’s actually a traditional
courting ritual, so.
Something for you.
No, no I can’t, I really can't
accept any more mittens.
No.
Whoa, that’s you.
You recognized?
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, what are
you doing?
Don’t you think we should wait,
until marriage?
Lavinia:
Taste my whip.
What?
Ahh.
(Whip-cracking)
I am a twisted, witchy,
creative, horny women and you
can’t accept that.
Dance.
Ahh!
That girl needs to feel fully
blindsided by a wild prank in
order to  commit to a marriage.
I literally thought I was being
kidnapped.
I’m tearing up my old dresses to
make bandages.
Hard to believe I used to wear
these dresses to look good for
my suiters.
Now the closest I’ll ever get to
a man
is if he wraps his hemorrhaging
leg wound in a piece of my silk.
(Ripping)
Girl that is dark.
♪♪